hey Elsa gum breasts my name is Pippa
welcome to undertale part 4 part 3 oh my
god what's a hot mess so we're just kind
of starting in the middle of this new
area looks like aa Pokemon and this guy
has been watching us I'm in a new setup
it's the same setup I just put these
foam things on the walls so it sounds
better uh I think it sounds a lot better
I I really enjoy the audio for once I've
never really been truly pleased with the
audio III did some spray paints on the
walls for fun and just just so it looks
less generic background everyone was
also saying like ASEAN market players
house know markiplier lives in LA I live
in UK so now you know with these white
things white [ __ ] things on the walls
that means no unless mark starts doing
it - goddammit alright ah
that being said I also have this now so
you don't have to see the [ __ ] whole
wall in my face no more steam
notifications
no more skype notifications hopefully
there will be no unsynched I had so much
problem with this series because I'm
recording on a whole new setup no one
cares I'll display I know a way right to
asko's castle no problem well actually
um that's just a tiny issue a long time
ago I made a robot named mettaton
mettaton originally I built him to be an
entertainment robot but you know like a
robotic TV star or something anyway
recently I decided to make him more
useful you know just some small
practical adjustments like a lengthy
anti human combat features um cuz when I
saw your coming I immediately decided I
have to remove those feature
unfortunately I may have made a team
see mistake while doing so and now he's
an unstoppable killing machine with a
thirst for human blood
hey hey hey hey hey hey but I'm
hopefully we were running doing what
most hundred percent gonna run into it
uh uh ah [ __ ]
did you hear something what is this
Jurassic Park check the water glass the
water glass genius oh no what is going
on oh yeah
welcome beauties to today's quick y'all
yes
quiz Singh oh boy I can already tell
it's gonna be a great show everybody's
gonna give a big hands for one [ __ ]
test that yeah yeah whoo never played
before gorgeous no problem it's simple
that's the only one bro what is this
like kool-aid man answer correctly or
you die Jesus Christ met that doughnut
axe all right cry screaming is against
the rules let's start with an easy one
what's the prize for answering correctly
more questions right sounds like you get
it a quiz show continues us
it's your terrific price what's the
king's Falls name uh a score dreamer
correct what a terrific answer
[ __ ] yes oh my god the quest show
continues enough about you let's talk
about me hahaha
Walter robots made up hopes and dreams
with Dell and magic snips and snails
sugar and spice too easy for you ha the
question continues here's another one
fire two trains train a and train B are
you [ __ ] kidding me
I think I know the answer of this one
it's ah are you kidding me
how many flies are in this jar the [ __ ]
what is all this
what monsters is it's froggit oh my god
are you [ __ ] kidding me I'm gonna die
I hate this game would you smoosh edge
goes heck yeah heck yeah heck yeah oh my
god I got it right what the [ __ ] how
many letters in the name it Oh for
[ __ ] sake damn it no no no can't you
read time to break out the big guns in
the dating simulator video game um you
kissed a cutie what it's me Mia's
favorite food
what
hahaha
ah us seriously
how can seated can you get I love it and
while you're completely wrong you
deserve some credit
I've seen her watch I've seen her watch
you on computer screen smiling when you
succeed shrieking when you fail and
always always whispering no wrong you
have to go that way oh my god I see you
bros Jesus Christ in its own way it's
just that love I think so I think so
bras with dr. alpha is helping you the
show has no dramatic tension we can't go
on like this but but this was just the
pilot episode next up more drama more
romance more blood [ __ ]
until next time darlings he just Rockets
away well that was certainly something
what the [ __ ] just happened that that
last question we he wasn't supposed to a
stable the moribund we're wait wait let
me give you my phone number
what is this base mom all over again
then then maybe if you need help I could
but when you get that phone it's ancient
it doesn't even have texting wait wait
it's please there a girl screaming and I
upgraded a fire it can do texting items
it's got a cheeky chain I even signed
you up for the Underground's number one
social network now we're officially
friends
a Jesus crisis awkward
I'm going to the bank Alfie's updated
status just realized I didn't watch
Undine fight the human what we're gonna
my god I'll fix up the decided well I
know she's unbeatable I'll ask her about
it later for now I got a call up the
human and guide them cat face I'm gonna
guess this way Oh God that's adorable
but I wouldn't I gonna flee oh god sorry
sorry my bad
what is this the Pokemon level I saw
this level of twitch pokemon plays and
it was the most painful thing ever
watched almost were just watching me
play there's the same I want thank you
holy [ __ ] we played more than three
hours yeah it is I hate using the phone
I don't want to do this lmao what goes
on II soon Thunder plain not on purpose
or anything
well we better escape then so this what
makes us jump okay love the music it
reminds me of Donkey Kong Country we're
a world country I don't [ __ ] it oh my
god I had my claw under the last digit
for five minutes
oh my god I'm just gonna do it I'm just
gonna call does he know that we can hear
him ring ring click where I was calling
hung up before yesterday oh my god oh my
god hey brick ah hi sod zip low Lisa
I mean alpha say hi the blue laces won't
hurt you if you don't know which one are
you have to be moving and
they won't add that book through yet
he's adorable Oh God oh my god I did it
girls haven't shook like that since
Undine called me to ask about the
weather so have to keep walking
oh my god I'm so sorry it's okay I'll
try and not love this a soundtrack damn
it oh sorry blue don't move I'm an idiot
did did it it's a switch [ __ ] yeah
okay good
oh my god I forgot to tell them where to
go it's a photo of a garbage man with
several pig litter I'm sorry
ring ah this here uh the northern always
say like I told you solve the puzzles on
the right of left I think you should go
to the right path like right to this
right right right
who are these cool guys the way to work
is blocked so I had to catch method on
show on my phone the special effects
were amazing today that human always
look real method on yeah he's the most
popular star in the underground his fan
club probably has at least two no three
dozen members that guy's pretty popular
wonder if it would be unfun if I
explained the puzzle oh my god is
literally you bros shoot the opposing
ship move the boxes to complete your
mission I don't know if I see what how
do I move the box okay
what position should they be moved to
but I can shoot the boxes oh my god well
set it what oh my god when you overthink
puzzles Jesus Christ man all right let's
do this one then how outfits here had
that flow Lane set it seems totally
impossible but as the Royal scientist I
have some tricks up my sleeve
I'll hack into it that hot land laser
database and take it out thank you
thanks this guy's looks dope finally
someone turned off that laser now that
we're free we can well uh I guess we'll
just keep standing here ha ha ha bring
it on out and suddenly a bunch of lasers
puzzles reaction but notice you prop my
roll like I can't school over there all
right well this one is a little bit more
complicated and
there we go nail that [ __ ] like a nail
your mother I'm so sorry I'm saying that
she's a lovely lady
I'm sure okay up please there we go
Illuminati science always good news
always Alfie's updated status whatever
I'll just explain it I think hey about
the puzzles on the left and right
they're a bit difficult to explain but
uh but you already saw them awesome whoo
yeah I love the puzzles in this game hey
it's kind of dark me isn't it
all right I'll hack it to the light
system and brighten it up the light
system oh well oh no oh no oh yay well
computers do the undergrad pre-med
cooking show cooking with a killer robot
oh it's my favorite show holy [ __ ]
pre-heat your oven because we got a very
special recipe for you today we're going
to be making a cake my lovely assistant
here will gather drink videos everyone
give them a big hand
whoo yeah that's right that's right
we'll need some sugar milk and eggs go
for it sweetheart I
all right well eggs milk and sugar
there you go great job to spit them in
the middle of the counter boom perfect
great job beautiful
we got all the Greens we need to bake
the cake it's a 50k to break it for the
cake if the way is hazy wait a mechanism
in a moment how could I forget we're
missing the mother bar ingredient what
the [ __ ] a human so oh my god they're
eating her and then they're gonna eat me
hello I'm kind of in the middle of
somethin e and wait a second couldn't
you make a could you use a could you
make a substitution in the recipe our
substitution you mean use a different
non human ingredient Wow uh what if
someone's vegan ha ha ha
vegan oh well that's a brilliant idea
outfit actually I happen to have an
option right here MTT bread always
convenient human soul flavor substitute
ok to which I just over it's just over
in that counter how convenient
well darling why don't you go get it I
feel like I should just go goddamnit
by the way our show runs at strana
strict schedule if you can't get the can
in the next minute I'll just have to go
back to the original plane so better
start climbing beautiful oh no that's
not enough time to climb up fortunately
I might have a plane when I was up
getting here for that at a few feet yes
you see that huge button that says jet
pack what watch this
jet packs this game just got infinitely
better are you kidding me are you
kidding me right now what is this there
you should head you have just enough
fuel to reach the top now get up there
what is this game it's he throwing hot
pockets
this is so accelerating oh my god
oh my god this game is just wonderful
but did it
Oh No
okay we did it mama
it seems you bested me but only because
you had the help of the brilliant dr.
Mathis oh I love to think about what
happened there without her
well toodles Oh No
oh yes I'm about to substitution haven't
you ever seen a cooking show before I
already baked the cake at a time to
forget it are you kidding me
Wow Bea we did it we really did it great
job out there well uh anyway let's keep
heading forward click this is so weird
an ominous structure looms in the
distance you're filled with
determination that does look very
ominous all right then see that building
in the distance that's the car as the
power of all power the source of all
power for the underground it converts
geothermal energy into magical
electricity by anyway that's where we're
going to go in the car is an elevator
directly to asko's castle and from that
you can go home click sounds great
sounds like a done deal as long as he
doesn't keep updating his Facebook I
think we'll actually get there I don't
know buy your brush but I'm well excited
please select the location um I don't
know right floor to love that sound
so soothing is that a monkey um heats
flames man remember my name heats flames
man heats flames man why should I
remember its name oh my god is he back
Jesus Christ what is he gonna do now
sorry I'm ed get what are you doing
creeping me out man what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you hey buddy what's up
you want buy a hot dog it's only thirty
G now buy on duck thanks kid
he's a dog yeah down ' dog it's chill
for hot dog toasty bun okay I love hot
dogs hey isn't it weird there's snow on
that guy's roof guess he's just too lazy
to clean it up that's probably the
reason why a right
Alfie's posted a picture dinner with a
girlfriend
smiley face is a picture of a cat girl
figure next to a ball of instant noodle
face cool skeleton 95 motion picture are
we posting hotcakes here's me and my
cool frame it's a picture of a Paris
flexing in front of a mirror he is
wearing sunglasses
giant muscular biceps are pasted onto
his arms the biceps are also wearing
sunglasses holy [ __ ] I need to see this
picture it sounds like the best picture
of all time all fits up there's a lull a
skeleton 95 that's a joke right cool
skeleton 95 updated status the only joke
here is how strong my muscles are that
is indeed a joke napstablook 22 has sent
you a friend request accept the request
[ __ ] it
what
a prawn yeah
can't hurt
how do you say apron is it like that a
prawn or a prawn hi it's dr. ralphus
this puzzle is kind of time-based
you see those switches over there you'll
have to place all three of them within
three seconds I'll try to help with the
rhythm click boom boom boom oh my god I
couldn't click weakest of the dialog
okay now prices third one hey looks like
you late needed to press to them oh my
god
ah this game is too much
I always ever decided that's the last
time I'll try to help you the puzzle
lmao and I walk here nope ring um hey
I'm gonna go to the bathroom so I'll be
my air for a bit I'm sure you can handle
this puzzle by yourself
oh why did I go here Oh
nailing it nailing it damn it god damn
it oh I got it
Paradis
look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
why did I do this why I do this why did
I do this I'm gonna edit now actually
that's how you sold a puzzle I'm an
idiot Wow am i that dumb sometimes I
have [ __ ] brain fart all over the
place I'll fix up that his status oh my
god people think new Mewtwo is better
than mew mew one Lola that's a joke
right
everyone knows mew mew two is better
come on alice is saved there's a piece
of cheese inside the computerized laser
sight the lasers are melted the edges of
the cheese stuck to the table Alf is
updated status oh my god don't they
don't they get it
don't they get it ruins Mew Mews entire
character arc I agree it really does my
mew-mew to review mew mew kiss acuity to
is neither kissing your cutie it's trash
Sara stars what mean review I thought it
was nice
hey you stop oh is those guys we've like
received an anonymous tip about a human
wearing a striped shirt they told us
they were wandering around hotline right
now I know it sounds super scary huh
well just stay chill will bring you
someplace safe all right huh what is it
bro the shirt they're wearing like what
about it bro are you thinking what I'm
thinking
bummer this is like mega embarrassing we
like actually totally have kill you have
to kill you in stuff like team attack
team attack oh god oh whoa whoa what is
happening
okay so I'm cleaning their armor oh my
god that's some sexist [ __ ]
he looks bothered by something oh my god
let's clean his armor this is ridiculous
I love it oh he's too bothered nowadays
attacks sweat pours from all right come
on let's clean his armor you pat are g0
two's chest like a muscular Bongo hey
stop that
hello haha what the [ __ ] is going on in
this game I don't think I understand
anything anymore okay let's let's keep
doing it zero one is polishing his face
so why am I supposed to do now how about
we clean his armor like hands off okay
what have we whispered to him be honest
with his feelings dude I can't I can't
take this anymore
not like this like sir - I like I like I
like you bro the way you fight the way
you talk I love doing team attacks with
you
I love standing here with the who
pouncing and waving out weapons NSYNC
zero - I I like want to stay like this
forever
ah I mean uh psyche gotcha bro haha zero
one yeah bruh do you want to get some
ice cream after that sure dude huh
zero one zero zero I look at each other
happily you won that's [ __ ] brilliant
Oh who's ever decided oops wait how's
the human doing a damn it
have some sighs ah
me and my clicky fingers hate me I hate
myself
please don't on that no not the box
again okay I am Bank another dark room I
don't worry my hacking skills I've got
things go oh no oh no are you serious
oh yay good evening here is in gentle
beauties this is mara dawn reporting
live from MIT news an interesting
situation is arising in eastern
heartland
fortunately our correspondent is out
there reporting left-brain coverage but
and please bets every news where did you
report I'll ten what if abusive anyway
oh boy others others oh ma it's a
complete nondescript glass of water but
anything can make a great story with
enough spin report this one yes
attention viewers our correspondent has
found our glass of water but what's
astonishing about this gossip on it is
how all interesting it is like all glass
of water it's complete of water glass
nitroglycerin wait a second it's not a
dynamite that's not a glass of water
that's a bomb oh no this news report
it's turning into a disaster report but
don't panic you haven't even seen the
rest of the room yet oh man it seems
everything in this area is actually a
bomb that dogs about that basketballs a
bomb even my words are frame correspond
it if you don't have used all the bombs
this big bomb will blow you to
smithereens in two minutes then you
won't be reporting live anymore
oh okay I get it how terrible how
disturbing a nine viewer wait someone
dropped off are going to love watching
this good
darling ring don't worry I install it
bomb defusing program on your phone use
the defuse option when the bomb is in
diffused zone now go get them alright so
there we go great job keep heading out I
try to go for the ones in the bottom
left Nick's oh my god what is this he
said bottom left
I need to step up my game if we're gonna
do this oh my god this is the most
exciting news report of my life
gotcha
my god this is so exciting
I could wit wit my pants gotcha
my god what a hero what a true American
Hero
gotcha this is so exhilarating great job
head for the center I'm using a iam
field to trap the glass of water in
there where
whew that was a close one well done
darling you deactivate it all the paths
if you didn't be activate them the big
bomb would have exploded in two minutes
now it won't explode in two minutes
instead of exploding - shotgun
goodbye darling wait what do I do
one two ah it seems the bomb isn't going
up that's because while you were
monologuing at f-fix um I changed
oh no you deactivated the bomb with your
hacking skills yeah that's what I did
cassius it seems I've been fooled again
garcy human cars you dr. ralphus for
helping so much but I don't curse my
eight wonderful viewers for turning in
god dammit why did they drop a chill
exam darling well we really showed him
huh hey I know I was kind of weird at
first but I really think I'm getting
more more more confident about getting
you so don't worry about that big dumb
robot I'll protect you from it and if it
really came to ready we could just turn
ah nevermind later okay alright well did
we just walk past it or no alright um
just go south perhaps no alright um
maybe over here oh yes this is it the
force field has gone out so we can go
here awesome that's sad that's
fantabulous that's a that's a word now I
invented it thank ring um I notice
you've been kind of quiet are you
worried about me meeting as a meeting a
score well don't worry okay as a king is
a really nice guy I'm sure you can talk
to him and with your human soul you
could pass through the bank so no way
alright just forget about it and smile
oh my God look at that face you look
like when I go my next mistake loves a
game wanna play Oh No well it looks like
red top hey guys how's it going welcome
to our parlor very interested in some
spider pastries all proceeds go to
spiders well then I will definitely buy
one it's a spider donut it looks more
like more rubbery than usual but I want
to check out the webs to make a purchase
all right
by a spider donut yes you didn't have
enough pie spiders
oh no all right um I ended up buying a
donut I I didn't want to but that girl
even though I told her no she she kept
staring at me in this creepy way and
licking her lips now I'm out of cash
well that was an expensive one was it
ring hi Ashley scary this room is like
the room we saw before there are two
parcels to the north and south you'll
have to solve them to proceed oh also
I'd like to say I don't really like
giving away puzzle solutions but if you
need help just call me all right
actually wait I have an idea let's be
friends on under net then you can just
ping me when you need help
oh wait we're already friends aren't we
I signed you up tonight you've been
reading my poster all time I got it here
so awkward
well I hope you agree with me about vmu
dip ah the awkwardness kids I'm cringing
yeah bill bill
yeah yeah yeah
all right we're going here first oh
never mind we're not going in first
oh sorry he said north and south I am an
idiot add blithering idiot
taffeta head it Fitbit Oh God
not because it's jealous volca you split
paying attention to you alright
volcanium is adorable
I don't want to do I don't want to serve
that oh it's one of these again and we
only have one shot did it ha ha ha ha
well well well congratulations to me hey
guys I was good I don't see my favourite
mettaton moment right when everything
looks the baddest he poses dramatically
like when he's on a cooking show and the
eggs don't turn out right are they face
is spinning my favorite matter on moment
is when he beats up the heel cheering
will it even if it's during what's
supposed to be a question ah Maradona
you might be my foot one of my favorite
characters so far
what a lovely guy am i right I think I
got the hots for him it is hot lions
after all so no I thought I [ __ ] it
I am terrible I forgot
blue means keep walking hey this side
doesn't have anything that they would
gotten you but would you want to watch a
human TV show together sometime it's
called a Mew Mew kissy cutie
uh sure alright it's so good uh my
favorites my furniture it's all about
this human girl okay
and she's Olsen amber like she realized
said hurry is no matter that her friends
like to serve despite a curse it's
really moving hope spoilers also this
sounds weird but she has a power she
controls the minds of anyone she keeps
it she gives the people in control
center fix her problems and remembered
anything after the kids I mean but if
she misses a kiss then and and also I
mean of course eventually she realizes
that controlling people okay well I
almost pulled the whole show but um I
think you'd really like it thanks I
think I like it too would you watch it
after you go through with all this now I
really really want to watch it oh my god
so much uh another puzzle
damnit
oh wait I did it wrong damn it
there we go
no I restarted it I am an idiot the [ __ ]
is wrong with me name which punishment
said okay okay
nailed it puzzles solved 100% yeah
awesome awesome yeah our cactus got a
click it you stopped to smell the
flowers but I did that
alright so now we go west to the West go
to win side go to waste
oh by the way I don't know what I'm
saying Oh dramatic I like it let's just
save it's probably a boss battle coming
up and we're filled with determination
and we're double filled with termination
an awesome and we're entering a mouse
hole oh god let's not walk on this hey
did you hear what they just said they
said a human wearing a striped shirt
would come through fire that they hate
spiders pair that they'd love to stomp
on them heard that they like to tear
their legs off hey I did that once when
I was a kid come on I don't do that
anymore
I heard oh god is that that they're
awfully sticky with their money huh you
think your taste is too refined for that
pastries don't you dare me I disagree
with that notion I think your taste is
exactly what this next batch needs well
I probably would taste delicious ooh
muffin traps looks adorable and I assume
we can
our money no no no no we're not gonna
give our [ __ ] you struggle to escape the
web Muffet covers her mouth and Google
site don't look so blue my dearie Oh God
I think purple is better look on you
you're trapped in a strange purple name
why so pale you should be proud
Muffit does a synchronized dance with
the other spiders what is going on
mother is so amused by your antics that
she gives you a discount proud that
you're going to make a delicious cake
if it pours you a cup of spiders Thank
You muffin so am I supposed to bribe her
like when I when I know it's gonna get
it difficult because the spider is
telling me like what's coming up my
porch a cup of spiders started to escape
nothing happened your soul can you'll
Saul is going to make everything spy
that have any happy every spider very
Adam English Oh God oh my god look at
that face you look like
Muffit there's a synchronized stance
with the other spiders I wish I could
see it um oh wow how rude of me I almost
forgot to introduce you to my pet it's
breakfast time isn't it have fun you two
oh god this is make me nauseous oh my
god
well it's pretty simple isn't it up down
up down up down up yeah hey oh god
please no please God God oh wow whee
oh rick i don't know about this come on
Morty we gotta go up Morty Oh Shh oh we
did it
muffin put a cup of spiders thank you my
fat I'm gonna keep struggling the person
who have wand s about you did it it did
it it o did it
Oh God my foot is up the web around you
thank you for that I wish I had more
food I don't what happens we pay her
let's try it later
you started to skip the web nothing
happening offered us a lot of money for
your soul oh god this could be it
it was dammit
all right so this one is difficult what
if we pay our money my food reduces our
tag this time your soul is good okay so
it gets a little easier
we don't Oh God it's still pretty hard
well before scope of spiders uh the
cupcake Oh cupcake is that the name of
her pet cupcake it's a cupcake all right
oh it is it is literally a cupcake I
didn't see you last time but it's
hilarious
no if I call a cupcake to be honest I'd
probably call a demon [ __ ] [ __ ] from
how Muffit Muffit
oh yeah ma I don't I never knew the
difference between Muffet 35 now I'm
just gonna have to go for it
oh my god third muffin attack come on no
come on
oh oh oh my god that was [ __ ] awesome
okay now we just got muffin again come
on we can do this
I forgot that there's this [ __ ] part
as well Jesus Christ come on come on
No
yes you're still alive whoo Oh my pet
looks like it's time for dessert
what is this huh a telegram for the
spiders in the ruins what they're saying
that they saw you and you helped donate
to their cause oh my this is been a big
understanding I thought you were someone
that hated spiders the person who has
for that soul must have been a different
human in the striped shirt sorry for all
the trouble oh I'll make it up to you
you can come back any time and for no
charge at all I'll wrap you up and let
you play with my pet again no thanks
just kidding
Oh I'll spare you now spare oh god we
did it
that was fun see you again Deary the
bosses are really challenging or they're
starting to get really challenging which
I really like I was worried that the
game is gonna be a little too easy but
to be fair it is very hard I can see
people really getting suck on these oh
that human oh this is beautiful
I love this guy go ahead babe oh my god
my one true love
what is this Shakespeare Oh oh that's
beautiful
what am I looking at here
oh my love please run away monster King
forbids your stay human must live far
apart even if it breaks my heart they'll
put you in the dungeon
it'll circuits and then you'll die a lot
really sad
you're gonna die
hey cry cry cry
I so sad it's happening yeah so sad so
sad that you're going through the
dungeon well Turtles damn it come on man
my other rocket oh no whatever should I
do my love has been cast away in the
debt a dungeon with a puzzle so
dastardly my paramour will surely perish
oh god it says puzzle again the horrible
colored title mail maze each caller tile
has its own sadistic function for
example a green towel sounds a noise and
then you must find monster red tile will
actually wait in a second
they went easy this puzzle 100 rooms ago
that's right you remember all the rules
don't you yes I do
great then I won't waste your time
repeating them oh and you'd better
because if you don't get through in just
30 seconds
flame okay got it
my poor love I'm so filled with grief I
can't stop laughing good luck darling
I guess a green one will spawn a monster
now
what am i doing oh my god this is
ridiculous
this is ridiculous
all right out of time
oh I'm so sorry
looks like you're out of time it comes
to flame darling
hey the cooler closing in getting cosa
oh my any minute now watch out I will
save you I'm hacking in the firewall
right now the firewall haha how would
this happen fall against by the
brilliant doctor alphys again that's
right
come on medic down give it up already
you'll never be able to defeat us not as
long as we work together your puzzles
over now go home and leave us alone
puzzle over
Alfie's darling what are you talking
about did you forget about the green
tiles do they make a sound then you have
to fight amongst well darling that
monster is me oh my god are we fighting
him now
let's see I'll let him you yell nothing
happened in sit darling Sagan this is it
darling singer back it's not your phone
you better answer it the [ __ ] hey this
seems bad but don't worry there's one
last thing I install in your phone
you'll see that you see that yellow
button go to this phones act menu and
press it you press the yellow button the
phone is resonating with this is a
darling say goodbye what now press n
[ __ ] you Merida no way I can't kill him
oh you defeated me how can this be you
wish stronger than I thought etcetera
how good he didn't die it looks like you
beat him you did a really great job out
there
all thanks to to you all thanks to you
what oh no I mean you're the one doing
everything cool I just wrote some
selling programs for your phone um hey
this might sound strange but can I tell
you something before I met you I didn't
really I didn't really like myself very
much for a long time I felt like a total
screwup Oh like I couldn't do anything
without without anything up letting
everyone down but guiding you has made
me feel a lot better about myself so
thanks for letting me happy um anyway we
um we're almost at the car it's just
past MTT return come on let's finish
this finish it we'll share
oh my god How long could you actually
make it through that'd be awesome
I'd really [ __ ] up hey it's you again
this is excellent here these two fellas
brought all my ice cream I can imagine
I've actually sold out of everything
sorry
wait I still got something for you a big
smile how about that yeah how about that
I imagine the ice cream would sell
better in this land ah but let's keep
walking through hey it sounds hey I
heard you going to go to Cole how about
grabbing some dinner with me first
yeah great thanks for treating me ha ha
ha oh hey hey I know a shortcut
what we're not going in there what what
what well here we are so your journeys
almost over huh you must really want to
go home Hey I know the feeling but oh no
maybe sometimes it's better to take
what's given to you down here you
already got food drink French is what
you have to do really worth it ah forget
it
I'm Rotem for you kid hey let me tell
your story so I'm a century in Snowdon
forest right I sit out here and watch
for humans it's kind of boring
fortunately deep in the forest there's
still Shh there's this huge lock door
and it's perfect for practicing
knock-knock jokes so one day I'm
knocking a man like you should I knock
him on the door and say knock knock and
suddenly from the other side I hear a
woman's voice
who is there so naturally I respond
dishes dishes who dishes a very bad joke
then she's just house with laughter like
it's the best joke she's ever heard in
100 years
so I keep him coming and she keeps
laughing so she's the best audience I've
ever had then after a dozen of them she
knocks and says knock knock I say who's
there old lady old lady who oh I didn't
not know you could yodel Oh delighted
whoo Wow
needless to say this woman was extremely
good hahaha we kept telling each other
jokes for hours eventually I had to
leave her purse got gets kind of cranky
with his bed without his present but she
told me she would come again and so I
did then I did again and again and the
thing now telling bad jokes through the
door it rules one day though I noticed
she wasn't laughing Freeman I asked him
what was up then she told me something
strange if a woman ever comes through
this door could you please please
promise me something
watch over them and protect them will
you not now I hate making promises and
this woman I don't even know one name
but someone who's sincerely like bad
jokes has an integrity you can't say
noting do you get what I'm saying that
promise I made to her you know what I
you know what would have happened if she
hadn't said anything buddy you'd be dead
where you stand
hey latinum Paco I'm just joking with
besides haven't I done a great job
protecting you I mean look at yourself
you haven't died a single time have I
have I have I hey what's that look
supposed to me am I wrong uh I don't
know
Hey my butt's starting to hurt
well that's all take care of yourself
kid if someone really cares about you
that my mom is it based mom I want to
meet base mom again well that was a
lovely stop at the restaurant the [ __ ]
is sad it has four nipples as I came in
I realized I forgot to make a
reservation but I don't want to look
like I'm messed up so I kept walking in
anyway now I'm just kind of consuming
you off this Figgis okay awesome
no that's reality show method ah I want
to watch the show
originally we do dug mazes with puzzles
in order to file human attacks but now
building things winding and confusing
it's some awful tradition you can't go
two feet without being up to your
armpits
in puzzles I agree that is the cutest
thing I've ever [ __ ] seen in my life
I walk at the car the mSATA is a maze
made of swappable parts that means we
can shuffle the layout at will boy was
today a fun day I share a lot puzzle oh
my god I don't even want to talk to that
thing
and ladies Ambrose that is another safe
I will end this episode there thank you
for watching another episode of
undertale really enjoying this uh and
i'll keep living a likes and i'll see
you bros in the next video stay awesome